and then he was like oh I cannot connect
to the Wi-Fi
so I hacked his phone looked at all his
wife's nudes all that stuff jacked up
jacked off a little bit came in your
pants I helped them connect to the to
the to the United Wi-Fi that's good
that's tight yeah it was very it was
very like rewarding
[Music]
closed circuit TV footage circulating on
Chinese social media shows a 65 year old
man distraught
he brings his phone crying into a police
station
and he asked police officers on duty for
help was he like I don't know how to
order Uber eat
no
close okay really close that was the
first thing he brought so close yeah so
because all people don't know yeah they
don't know it's so close no they're
they're actually just pictures of his
dead wife on the phone and and but he
can't access them anymore and he thinks
the photos are gone oh that's really sad
he goes
it's just desperate he just doesn't know
where to go oh okay and then the police
was like you just have to
Ctrl R to the police are said on a phone
PC one the police said it's a routine
for him to look at his deceased wise
pictures on his phone everywhere oh
that's sad bro look at his so yeah he
pulls up pictures of his wife on his
phone uh every day and today they're not
coming up oh so what happened he didn't
charge his phone he's like I don't I
have an old phone I don't know what's
going on and then he's like I don't know
where to go [__] software updates
dude the applesauce on you dude you
don't don't download that [__] say no
they [__] you up huh [__] yourself I
knew it oh but then but you wanna oh you
want to get oop you want to get Uber
guess what they're like you have to
update your [__] and I'm like [__] you
I'm standing with Lyft [__] you oh yeah
that's what it did stand your ground
dude don't let him do that too you
really don't update anything no I don't
I don't trust them because the planned
office lessons they already did to us
before and we trust them again yeah how
many times they gotta beat us down
before we [__] stand up I don't know
that just lets me have a new iPhone all
the time so I'm kind of happy that it
breaks yeah because I get new iPhones oh
that's really cool nice bragging dude I
have Team Mobile so they're literally no
but then what you do is you just turn
your last iphone in and they give you a
price on that and then like you get a
good deal on the new iPhone yeah but
you're still spending money so they got
you yeah
and you're locked into a plan by the way
I wanted to switch so many times for my
iPhone I'm like oh please let me switch
because like Samsung's cool and like
their lights are crypto people like me
and but then if you try to switch you
lose all your pictures too oh yeah buy
paid 30 bucks a month for unlimited
because like I'm with spectrum and they
had this cool deal going on and when I
was getting business Spectrum they're
like you want to add some lines and I
was like [__] yeah so then I get a good
deal
I don't know I don't know have you guys
ever had that happen it's really sad
when like an old person comes up too and
they need help with something it's and
it's like yeah it's pretty heartbreaking
you know if it's too sad I just say no
yeah I walk away oh you don't I just be
like
you've been on this Earth longer than me
you had so much time to learn this
technology like you lecture that you're
dismissive dude come on man you had so
many years to get it together you were
born
before this technology came to be dude
there was I came after there was an old
Asian lady that pulled up to me as I was
walking to the gym and she's like she's
clearly blocking a whole intersection to
come like ask for help I don't know why
she spotted me but she goes and we're in
like South Pasadena she goes hey uh I'm
lost I don't know what my GPS stopped
working she pulled out of like her
TomTom or whatever and it was like black
and I was like okay I don't know what to
do about that and then she goes can you
tell me how to get to LAX
and I was like
damn from where from south of Pasadena
and I was like you just got ahead on the
110 that way just go that way and she
had her she had her [__] her
directions on her phone but she just was
like so distracted she's on a bicycle
[Laughter]
the lime scooter yeah yeah
just tell you it's gonna take you four
days and I think I think she was I think
she was doing Uber
which was like a dagger and I was like
what do you mean wait she was driving
she was driving she was the Uber she was
like can you can tell me how to get to
LAX heartbreaking dude I was like I'm
sorry like you just gotta head to the
110 that way you didn't know how to tell
her to get to LAX but it was just like
she wasn't gonna remember it yeah it's
two it's too direct for tomtom's black
dude 110 South over 105 West I was like
I was like I gotta go train somebody I
can't be here like I'm already [__] I
gotta go in bro and she's on a bicycle
yeah
it's rough dude and it broke I felt bad
but I was like there's nothing I can do
what am I gonna do I don't know give me
the phone so this old couple right they
came up to me and they're like hey do
you know where the Duke's Restaurant is
and I'm like um I think it's in the next
building yeah I think it's in the next
building top floor is it Hawaii yeah and
then they go
are you sure it's not in this building
and I was like you're trying to [__]
you're the one asking me yeah go look
there what the [__] was the attitude so
I said you're right it's up there
and I saw them walk upstairs and I'm
like that's right
escalators broken it's in the bathroom
too it's all the way out in the left
[__]
dude going you know like it's been so
long since I worked customer service
right yeah and like I forgot how [__]
rude people are like just working at the
restaurant and like you just being chill
right and they come up to you and they
have questions and then they're not even
buying nothing and then you're just
trying to help them out but they still
act like hella entitled yeah some people
are just like that yeah I can't wait
dude until I can like have [__] you
money and then I'll just have a business
so I could talk [__] that's all I'm
gonna do yeah to them isn't it like
those restaurants who the waiters get to
talk [__] to the customers yeah it's
like Dave's Last Resort or something
yeah Dick's Last Resort I went to one in
San Antonio I was at Riverwalk in San
Antonio and I was walking by and I guess
the the guy who's supposed to be meeting
everyone stands outside and he like kind
of talks [__] to everyone outside yeah
yeah and he goes he goes nice shorts bud
and he was I thought he was talking
about Buddy and I was like oh [__] and
he goes no I'm talking to you [__]
and I started laughing and then as soon
as he said it he was like
he was like
if I saw your [__] ears no no I think
I I started and I think he as soon as he
said it he realized he [__] up yeah
and then he just was like
okay I'm sorry man I'm sorry man I used
to say trying to move my buds like when
we're alone yo that's so old school
that's so crazy I'd laugh just I bro I'm
shock hearing it I started laughing
because I thought he was talking to my
boy and I was like oh said he lugged
your shorts oh my God and then he looked
at me it was like I'm talking to you
gentleman and I was like what what I
started laughing bro he said he was like
do you think he said that because he's
like because he's like oh man now it's
about race but I'd like to sure
oh
[__] he wasn't Chinese I like those
waterproof barbell Brigade shorts he's
like I think he's Filipino or something
he's recently ambiguous that guy's not
from China what have I done I messed up
oh last time I was at Home Depot I saw
the uh the Home Depot employee get
frustrated with this like old Chinese
lady because she was showing him
pictures on her phone and she couldn't
articulate what she wanted and he was
just like I don't know I don't know
and so I went up and I was like hey what
is it and she couldn't speak to me
either because like I don't speak
Chinese but she was like showing me and
it wasn't that hard to figure out she
was looking for doorknobs but the
problem was that it was doorknobs for
her business and the doorknob on the
other side is a different knob so she
needed both knobs but that guy was like
no you have to get both like he couldn't
get that it's that you know they sell
him in twos yeah but I'm like yo there's
a whole other section with her
individual so I just went with her I'm
like here's this snob that's that one
and then this is that one and then she
was like oh thank you I'm like the
[__] employee couldn't figure that
out so this story that's why he's an
employee that's like you're a
businessman that's beautiful and by the
way this sad story takes a beautiful
turn so the officers weren't able to
help him at first because he had lost
his phone right so his phone was gone oh
and they retraced his steps using
surveillance footage and they found that
he had left his phone in a plastic bag
with a bunch of fruit for some [__]
reason of course because he see now I
don't know but they they found it they
found his phone
inside the bag probably as he was like
opening his door he shoved it in a bag
real quick just like so we could grab
the door and then
um to safeguard the photos that he had
of his wife which were intact on the
phone
um they gave him a disc of all of them
downloaded damn that is extra mile right
there holy [__] what's where is this
good this is in China wow and they were
of his wife's ass and titties oh that's
the best because they were jacking off
to his new to her nudes first that's
what I said and then they said yo we
saved this on a floppy for you yeah they
made copies for themselves yeah yeah
they're like yo your wife she was bad
they labeled him too for him they said
ass titties lips and then they said and
then they said and then they italicized
lips too so that he had them all [__]
lips and the lip lips yeah you don't so
I I did help an old guy I actually on my
flight here today I mean not today a
couple days ago he was sitting next to
me
and he saw that I was able to watch
movies on my phone and then he was like
oh I cannot connect to the Wi-Fi
so I hacked his phone looked at all his
wife's nudes all that stuff jacked up
jacked off a little bit came in your
pants helped them connect to the to the
to the United Wi-Fi that's good that's
tight yeah it was very it was very like
rewarding love that that's cool man
that's really cool man I do help old
people I don't just scold them for being
dumb like yeah or send them to restrooms
on the top floor hey she was being mean
yeah that sucks when they do that she
was asking me for directions and then
questioning me oh dude did I show you
guys the um when you know how like
outside my studio I have a camera facing
the intersection and people crash dude I
saw the last video yeah there was one a
few months ago where this this like work
van was making a left someone didn't
stop me to slam straight into him and
then they were the person that ran it
was saying it was the van's fault and
then I went I this is my protocol I go
outside I see if everyone's okay and
then I offer footage to the person that
like thinks it's not their fault or
whatever and it was like a Korean family
in the van like you know those like they
got like a store or something so it's
like four of them
um and then uh I I was like no it was
their fault I was telling them that and
then um I gave him the video I didn't
give the other guy the video I just gave
it to the Korean family I'm like yeah
you can see right here you guys stopped
and then they kept going and they were
like oh thank you they're so nice and
then um
I went back into the into the studio and
then they knocked on the door uh like an
hour later and they had brought me like
this uh there's like a plastic bag full
of Arizona Iced Teas yeah it's like
every flavor that's your jam yeah oh
sorry like this is all we can give you
but I hope you like it's okay I was like
dude that's so sweet that's so nice it's
a little thing that's why the other
guy's an employee you're a business
owner come on baby isn't that a sweet
gesture I want to get some too a bunch
of Iced Teas what's the best one you
know what I'm you're not gonna like it
but I like the original sweet tea I
don't like it is that the Arizona
ginseng strawberry kiwi [__] every
[__] time I like the black and white
the regular sweet tea I like the best I
love the regular ginseng one ginseng I
like the one with the yin yang sign
don't touch me don't touch me push them
on the front push them on the floor he
has to go on a frame the table editors
editing amount of frame I don't have to
straight
[Laughter]